Oh No.
Nobody Dominion by that.
Okay.
No tomatoes.
Oh No,
I'm so sorry.
Thank you very much for following us.
He'll just commit concessions does,
you could send bill and people in America will over.
The word can misstep was him.
It's a fashion.
If you do
hit your sister.
All right,
cool.
So,
um,
let's start with your name.
So,
so what's your name?
My name's I seen on a good day.
And where are you from?
Um,
I'm from Egypt.
And um,
when did you start playing soccer?
Okay.
I started playing soccer when I was around eight years old.
Oh.
I was a kid with some point of his life.
Well,
my parents were getting a divorce.
I was just looking for something to put all my energy and it was just like a
simple getaway from everything.
My grandfather was like a father to me.
You just go with me like your goalkeeper skit on his way back from a business
trip.
You just go me the shoes,
shirt,
the gloves.
So I was like,
I'll give it a try.
[inaudible]
right.
Go ahead,
Scott.
The very first day I was drained.
What did keep his coach and I was diving for the ball as if like I was diving
into the water
coach came up the music cue on this site.
From there there'll be the head coach of the national team.
Watch,
need.
The next thing we knew we got a call.
You're all this club.
To me it was like,
oh my God,
is this,
is this happening?
And uh,
my dad was in the happy that it wasn't my career.
He's like,
I know you're going to quit at some point and just work with me.
I kept training day and night,
day and night,
all my own.
I was offered a scholarship to school at Florida.
I took it.
I paid for a semester.
I dislocated my knee.
Okay.
It was one of the worst injuries I've ever gotten.
I was starting to get a grip of everything and then
boom.
It was all gone
and
just things seemed really tough.
I lost my grandfather.
The figure that I took as my father,
the figure that I looked up to in my entire life.
It just felt like
everything now is going.
I went to college back home.
I just started working like that
and at that point I just didn't think I was,
I was ever going to get back into splits.
Yeah.
I just felt like I wasn't going anywhere.
I just give up soccer.
It was,
it was one of the most difficult decisions I've ever had to make in my life.
Yeah.
But it was a must.
My sister kept nagging me every single thing to join her,
the train that the club in the morning,
it was just functional training back then.
I started training with a friend of mine and all I was doing was honestly like
researching,
reading articles and I was just implementing the workouts we got from soccer.
It just like ignited something in me.
I was really passionate that developing athletes,
like I got the opportunity to broaden the states in Spain,
the good physically radiating ways.
I never,
I never knew it was possible.
I saw how skilled players are here and I thought to myself,
I actually should help develop and giving them the opportunity that they would
never get anywhere else.
But my friend was like,
uh,
he had a different vision and I had my own vision so I decided to take off and I
started at ignite
when they started ignite.
I didn't have any money,
but I knew where I was going.
You started off with six people in a borrowed gym space that jumped up to 60
people in a matter of weeks.
Like you could see the change in character and I'll be looked at themselves how
they felt.
Everyone would come up to us and be like,
you've changed my life.
I don't know how to thank you.
I started
getting investors.
We started opening other branches.
I started traveling to take certifications and I just wanted to know as much as
I could about the human body and mind
go
one 81 90 kilos.
It was difficult at the beginning to have people accept what we're doing as
science.
I didn't care how much money I was making at the beginning.
I have to train off these for free.
I have to work my ass off almost 20 hours a day to get people to understand what
we're doing.
I would sleep two to three hours at night to program for my athletes.
There were times where I would sit in my car and,
and I just cry.
Not seeing a way forward,
but I liked the thing.
Things take time to happen.
It's all about hard work and just giving us time.
I go to a call from an athlete,
um,
started training just a little bit drunk and just jumps.
So
four,
he's his own coaches going to leave it.
Well,
this is what I want.
These are the people I really want to help.
I just don't want to just be another trainer.
I want to be the training I want to be.
The one specializes in,
in training these pros who specializes in changing lives.
Oh,
there's a train started standing out because started asking where they retrain
it.
Word of mouth started rewarding
and then one thing just slept in another and I went from getting the top players
in the league,
the soccer teams themselves.
It was called Keith the show against it.
Actually.
It was like,
are you fucking insane?
Are you outta your mind quitting your family business?
They start from scratch.
Are you insane?
It's something you already have.
You're all going to start all over again.
He didn't understand that was strengthened,
booked something on my own.
We saw,
you just called me off.
In our culture in Egypt,
there are certain jobs or certain carriers that are sort of an embarrassment.
Coaching was one of them.
It didn't make a difference at all.
I was helping more people prosper in their work and their careers,
and that in itself to me was like really fulfilling.
I've lived most of my life with my grandfather.
He was a great person.
He was a great man.
He was always giving back to society.
He was always giving back to everyone around me.
I saw how fulfilling it was to him and it just grew that into me.
I guess
when I first say ignite,
I was training one pro athlete.
Today,
my team and I,
we train over 200
the feeling I get when when one of my athletes just advances in their career,
it's big.
It's bigger than the game itself.
[inaudible].